perhaps the biggest test
of them all we have
nihal sarin from team kramnik
uh for those who
who play play a lot or watch a lot of
chess online
i'm sure you know nihal uh he's uh
one of the strongest and uh
he's one of the strongest blitz and bull
players in the world as
well as being well over 2600
in classical and i think he's only 16 or
17 years old
so this is going to be a tough challenge
but
i think i'm afraid
i will go e4 in this game
and uh either he's not ready or he's
doing the old gambit of uh
waiting a little
waiting a little and then and then
making
his first move no abu satyar is not he's
not playing
so there are there are a lot of strong
grandmasters but i think niall is the
strongest
so i think i'm going to go for another
sort of
closed closed ruy lopez here
as i had against zhang up to malik
earlier
and so i call this closed while others
like
after castles um
castles or um castles knight e4 and so
on the game would be
sort of more more open
and this is a little bit of a weird way
to play as white but
i think it's been pretty popular
recently
um we're trying to develop a little bit
more actively with c4 and knight c3
and what should i do after knight d7
i don't know let's go bish p3 94
i think i'll take i think i'll take and
take on d7
otherwise my bishop could be really poor
and here i was hoping
i just missed cb2 how can i miss that
it's like the easiest move
anybody's ever missed in the history of
missing moves
i would say that not only verges of on
being embarrassing that is actually
embarrassing
but never mind we'll try and save it
please there are some scenarios here
where my knight could be stronger than
his bishop which is kind of hemmed in by
this pawn
on d4 so
this could be fine
but like objectively only in terms of
saving saving the game
to to win from this position would be
would be a tough ask
even in blitz but i'll try of course
and uh he's spending
oh boy
i missed this as well okay now i'm
probably just losing
okay this has been a really
an embarrassing game
if i'm not losing here there's
pretty much no skill involved in that
that's just luck because i hadn't seen
any of this
just pure
disgusting luck
bish b5 i guess rook d1
rook c8 maybe looks suspicious to say
the least
yeah he's he's ambitious he's not gonna
go for the draw that easily yeah rook b1
the problem with queen h2 and then d3
i think that that was just losing on the
spot and yeah i was really worried about
um rook c8
i'm probably just losing now
queen b3 there's rook c3 nothing to be
done there
do i have anything else than queen d7
probably not
i think anything wins here rook c3 or
yeah rook c3 queen g4 is maybe not too
clear maybe rook c2 is the cleanest
queen g3 is a decisive threat
can i do anything at all here
i don't think i can 23 and queen h2 are
threats
king f1 queen of three let's come over
okay i have to
try to hustle him
every day um hustling i'm not
gonna be successful here i think
let's hope he's gonna be slow today
but it doesn't seem very likely oh he
gave up a pawn
trying to be as annoying as possible
tricky move okay let's let's see him try
and
oh request e7 is not
even uh still my trick there okay
oh and then i pre-moved myself out of it
okay good game
good game yo uh but that was
a pure embarrassment on my side
like you there is losing
and then there's
and then there's this
games where you don't even get going
but still uh full credit to yale he
played
he played he played a perfect game